fighting between Israel and Hamas is the
worst that we've seen since 2009 what
began as a limited conflict has
escalated into a major Israeli ground
offensive into Hamas held Gaza it's
resulted in hundreds of deaths here's
what happened and what it means it
started with the murder of three Israeli
young men in the West Bank they were
students they were kidnapped and killed
Israel responded to this because it
believed that the killings were done by
Hamas operatives it arrests a large
number of mosques people in the West
Bank and launched airstrikes into Gaza
Palestinians from Gaza fired rockets in
response Israelis were furious and a
Palestinian boy was murdered by six
Israelis essentially from what Israeli
police say as an act of revenge or over
his cousin was beaten an Israeli police
custody this led to a wave of anger on
the Palestinian side on the morning of
July II Hamas launched a wave of 40
rockets in the direction of Israeli
towns with very little guidance for
aiming their don't often hit targets or
produce many casualties but nonetheless
create a climate of terror inside Israel
these rocket attacks were the first that
Hamas had claimed responsibility for
since 2012 the last major conflict in
response Israel launched more strikes in
Gaza as part of what Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu said was an
effort to make Hamas pay a heavy price
by July 11th 100 Palestinians had been
killed by about a thousand Israeli
airstrikes by July 14th the total
casualties had exceeded the 2012
conflict and then on July 17th Israeli
troops entered Gaza to root out tunnels
into Israel that will allow Hamas to
strike Israeli targets were to send
soldiers in on the ground to attack
Israeli cities for military bases
after the ground offensive casualties
have skyrocketed we've come a long way
from 2009 when the Obama administration
came into office thinking that he'd get
the two sides on the same side I just
get it a peace agreement done let alone
the heady optimism in the 90s that we
saw about israeli-palestinian peace the
sad path that led to an incredibly
devastating ground offensive in Gaza has
Illustrated just how hair-trigger the
israeli-palestinian conflict is even
slight provocations even things that
might not be planned by one side or the
other one can lead to massive
escalations and violence there's just
too much mistrust and too much division
to be able to solve these problems any
time in the near term that's the sad
truth of this conflict
[Music]